[Music]
with kindness
[Music]
as california slides into crisis mode
residents are hitting the road yes blue
cities keep thugging out residents are
bugging out
as u-haul dropped the scoop that
everyone's fleeing a state with streets
filled with
poop
according to something called the u-haul
growth index my favorite kind of growth
index after my sweatpants
oh god there weren't enough trucks
for californians fleeing their state
last year that's because the state's
motto has gone from eureka to eureka of
homeless urine
but people are getting sick and tired of
the bs policies that have turned their
state into a lawless liberal hellhole
you get all the dirt and danger of the
third world plus avocado toast that
costs 14 bucks
between smash and grab robberies and
home invasions you also have coveted
mandates the homeless and worst of all
prince harry and meghan markle
talk about a royal flush
so there's more than enough reason to
pull up stakes they'd leave the golden
shower state and head for greener
pastures and those passers will have
less fertilizer on the ground that's for
sure according to that same u-haul
report texas florida tennessee and south
carolina and arizona saw the biggest
gains in u-hauls coming in versus going
out so like a person with two broken
arms on election day they're voting with
their feet
i just got that yeah thanks
jerk
and what do the destinations have in
common other than that they all love me
well they're all red which means
unfortunately they also love kill mead
how much for a truck to haul me away
from him
you booked me i did
i did
psychological problems i have kennedy
you know you are from uh that part of
the world and now you're over here um it
seems like when people should people be
leaving the blue states or should they
be sticking around and trying to fix it
i wish the good people would stick
around and try and fix it and i i wish
they would start with california
politics
something that is so
monotonous it is a one-party state that
gave us kamala harris and gavin newsom
and nancy pelosi yes and eric swalwell
and adam schiff right you know that's
that's how bad the environment is this
state and i love california i know that
you're from california and people don't
understand that who just hear these
awful stories but you know when you
spent a lot of time there you do feel
kind of defensive for it but you know we
are losing our reasons to keep standing
up at the place they've even blown legal
weed yeah they have they have such a
massive black market right now because
of the high taxes and the high
regulations that if people are going to
get high they're going to go to you know
some dealer on the street corner yeah
i've had it with that gladys
hell yeah they're just polluting the
city i actually went to the legal weed
place last week and it was uh
very low powered stuff there i was very
disappointed so i defecated in the
parking lot too much testing yes much
regulation too much red tape no good
weed there you go greg jim
jim what do you make of this trend going
from one place to the other well maybe
look maybe the celebrities can sing
imagine again
and that will keep people from moving
maybe that will do it because it works
so well the first time yeah i forgot
about that but that's got to be
embarrassing for people in l.a to be
driving around a u-haul instead of a
mercedes
you know
look it's going to be culture shock
because someone moved from california to
texas yeah so now you know when they go
to a steakhouse they can't order a
ribeye made out of tofu you know
an actual ribeye it's funny though
because when you think about uhauls it's
so depressing kat right whenever you
have a u-haul it's like that means you
you're like moving out from somebody you
broke up with
do you know what a u-haul is i know what
a u-haul is it's a plague i associate a
u-haul with hiding
so i don't have to help yeah oh there
you go
because when i move i get so stressed
about moving and i don't know why
because i never do anything
that's true you're not well look at your
arms you'd be the worst person to ask to
move
i gave cat a couch oh yeah she had other
people moving yeah you still have that
couch no but i i've never to this day
never purchased the couch i got her free
couch when i lived alone and then i
moved in with uh cam and he had a couch
i brought great couch stuff that's on
the i have i i don't buy it i just got a
dowry no you bought it on the couch my
lady look
it wasn't my dad i think paid him a lot
but um
it's stressful because it's like how
much money do i want to spend on the
couch and then what color do i want the
couch to be and then what other stuff am
i gonna have to go with the couch and
then it's so stressful and you have to
get it there so that's why i just before
you gave me the couch i had lawn chairs
in my apartment there you go god you
know well brian any more questions
you actually literally put questions
you live in a u-haul right i mean
you're constantly moving you're like
excrement through a human bowel never
never stopping so this is like
i don't know
fulfill that rest of what i was going to
say with an earnest question true all
right um
i don't live in a u-haul
but my u-haul experience is not a good
one yes uh so what i did is i moved six
blocks away right so i just said to
myself i'm gonna get a u-haul i'm going
to do it myself so i filled up the whole
u-hole with all my stuff and i lost the
key
uh so i ended up not being the guy goes
i rented from u-haul so i leased u-hauls
to be able to rent a guy like you so
there was no backup key so i ended up
having to put it into my jeep cherokee
little by little and then they ended up
having to tow the u-haul out of my
driveway but let me just tell you a
story that'll actually help your show
yes
so basically you just told me a story
that wouldn't help my show you could
edit it this story does need help i mean
tennessee south carolina and arizona
round out the top five of the red states
which of course florida and california
arizona's already changed yeah purple uh
you're already seeing some movement in
tennessee we know what's happened in
nashville you you guys are just there so
i think a lot of them are going and
they're not leaving their values behind
they're trying to ruin the states
because they don't believe it was their
fault you know what and the thing is i
do believe do you have ever told you my
waiver plan that if you move from blue
to red you have to sign a waiver that
you don't vote for two years not because
we don't like you or anything we just
want you to experience what it's like
for two years not to screw up a state or
a city right but that'll never happen
because i think that's unconstitutional
i believe right now yeah i don't think
that matters anymore no it doesn't at
least to me i i the constitution always
overrated right did you really read that
the paper is really old like how do they
write on that parchment
[Laughter]
you would think they would have broken
to the copy machine too yeah because
they made so many copies because we all
had to follow it that's true it's
ridiculous hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else